This is a question for the I F P.
Given the potential blowback from certain international powers,
was South African right to go to the I C J over Israel's war on Gaza?
Can you just repeat that?
Given the potential blowback from certain international powers.
Okay.
Was South Africa right to go to the International Court of justice
over Israel's war on Gaza?
Uh, I think first of all,
we need to clarify our position as the party
in relation to our foreign policy outlook.
We believe, uh,
as a party in democracy, uh,
liberties of different countries and the rule of law.
I think as the South African government having gone there to court,
I think it was on the basis of what they thought, eh,
Israel is doing to Gaza and at a particular point
they believe that Israel is actually intruding or actually causing, eh,
what you call cause, eh,
casualties in Gaza. But as the IFP,
we are saying let us as a country,
if we're in charge of government,
we're not going to go to court.
We're going to try and facilitate between these two countries and,
and ensure that they actually find a common solution
between these two countries
on the basis of negotiations
as opposed to taking a part where we neglect one part
and actually cause suspicions
have said that they are actually eh,
killing people in Gaza.
The IFP says if you want to play an independent role,
if you want To maintain your impartiality,
you don't have to be sent to be taking part.
Bring both parties on board and make sure that you mediate.
Because us taking side with Gaza is meaning to say
we don't have to deal with the Israel people
and we're not even to listen to them.
And we are compromised
in terms of having to persuade them to seize fire.
Thank you, Mister Town.
Can South Africa bring the impartial on the Gaza genocide?
Well, firstly,
as the N. C,
we've been consistent about our support
to all the oppressed people of the world.
And we understand the role of the international community
in ensuring that those people are able to gain their freedom.
We understand because we needed the international community
when we were fighting for our freedom.
We've got the children of Cuba that died in Puto Carnavale.
They died because they were fighting our cause,
the cause of the Namibians,
so that we are able to get our freedom.
So, yes,
countries made sacrifices.
We've got many countries that have made sacrifices
to ensure that we're able to achieve our freedom.
And we believe that we have an obligation as a country
to support those who are oppressed.
And it is not an Assumption
that the people of Palestine are discriminated against,
that they are oppressed. The reality is that,
in fact, when you are a Palestinian living in Israel,
you get text more than in Israeli.
The reality is that they Build these walls.
They are parted walls that separate people from their livelihoods.
Literally building a wall between you and your farm so that you,
you drive an hour to get to your farm
to be able to gain your livelihood.
That is discrimination. That is oppression.
And all we did was to use the international system.
The world met at Breton Woods.
The world agreed on establishing international mechanisms
of governance, of accountability.
The International Court of justice was created by this world.
And all we did was to make use of that.
And that has been justified through the rulings that have been made.
What are the DA's thoughts on this question?
First of all, first of all,
the Democratic Alliance supports a two state solution.
We are wanting firstly,
to make sure that we've got an independent Israel, an,
an independent Palestine and a secure Israel.
The South African governments,
I won't continue until the booming stops.
The South African government,
please, can we just allow her some respect?
The South African government's decision to, uh,
approach the I C. J is what it is
and we support it. And now we'll wait for the I C.
J's outcome. But we want to be clear about where we stand in this war
in the Middle East. No..
1 is a two state solution.
Number two, we are on the side of peace.
We want to make sure that these two countries can coexist as a,
as a political Party that supports the rule of law.
We will abide by the I. C.
J's findings on the matter
on whether or not there's a genocide taking place in the Middle East.
And that's what we have committed ourselves to.
Thank you so much. The f,
f,
no. Look,
look, the majority of countrys in the world
and majority of the people in the world are against Israelis Zionist,
racist and colonial war over Palestine.
That has been demonstrated
on recurrent votes in the United Nations General Assembly,
which are undermined by the US imperialist government through the veto,
which the UN must remove with subsequent changes of the UN system.
There's nothing wrong with South Africa did
in approaching the International Court of justice to hold Israel
backed by the United States accountable.
Also, we need to appreciate everyone else,
I'm sure students will, will pay close attention to that,
that we are moving away from a unipolar world
where there is just one dominance by one imperialist
forcing the form of America.
There's beginning to be emergence of multipurality in the world now
where there is different sources and bases of power.
And that includes the People's Republic of China,
the Russian Federation, India.
And these are our friends who can't be intimidated
on whatever foreign policy discussion that we take
in whatever foreign policy decision that we take.
We can never be intimidated by the west.
We do not need them because in any way
their relationship with us
as The African continent has either been colonial or new colonial.
So, we are fine without the west.
We are now aligning with the progressive forces.
Our position on Israel is correct
and we must continue to intensify it
and close the embassy of Israel here in South Africa.
Last week. Action Essay.
Well, first of all,
I think, um,
when your country goes to the International Court of justice
on behalf of your whole nation,
they should actually seek a mandate from the nation.
You don't just go there and do your own thing
as if you represent everybody.
You don't. And if you don't believe me in the last election.
Seventeen million people voted,
18 million didn't, 10 million voted for this government.
And tomorrow, if half of those,
who are, quarter of those 18 million voters,
you won't be there anymore.
So, think and listen.
Secondly, let's talk about the facts.
There was a provocative attack on Israel and what happens,
it's a fact. There was at an attack and people were killed,
innocent civilians were killed.
And in war, you get disproportionate response.
And there is a disproportionate response.
We believe that there's a disproportionate response.
But let me tell you another fact.
I have seen protestations all over the free world
of hundreds of thousands of people
meeting in the main cities of the world
calling for the extermination of Israel.
That is wrong.
I have never seen Israelis protesting in the hundreds of thousands
calling for the extermination of Gaza or Palestine
so here's the thing
Gaza is a Muslim country Israel is a Jewish country
and Mister Tao says that the ANC supports all oppressed people
the Jewish people are one of the most depressed people in the world
they had the greatest genocide against them ever in mankind
thank you so much um Sarah
I'm gonna go rogue just one more time uh
before we go to the audience and I wanna ask everyone else
start with you Mister Dowell um
some people have said that the electoral process
the electoral system and in extension
the constitution should be amended
to allow voters to pick and elect their preferred choice of president
what is the a N C's view on this?
Well firstly should we
as a country continue to discuss options on electoral systems?
We certainly believe as the N C
that we should be able to discuss those
we should open the conversation
particularly as we find ourselves in a different situation where
in fact uh
particularly at local government
we've experienced uh the coalition governments and the
the collapse of these coalition governments
so we should be able to think about electoral systems
and how we enhance our electoral system
our view is that there's been adult changes to the electoral system
because of court challenges
about participation of independence and other mechanisms of that
and our view is that
you require comprehensive review of the electoral system
and to be able to update The electoral system,
remember, we agreed on an electoral system many years ago.
We are great on the basis of a breakthrough to get to where we are.
There's nothing wrong with us
sitting down and reviewing what we've experienced
and determine whether the first past
the post system is most appropriate.
But we are saying that it is a conversation that must be heard
to the people of this country
so that collectively can arrive at a decision around
what is the most optimal electoral system in our country.
Thank you so much. So we wait.
Does the P R system still work?
Uh, do we need to pick or elect,
vote for our own president?
I think that certainly the mic is not working.
I think certainly South Africa needs to move towards, uh,
electoral reform in its entire.